if you want to know why some species eat
their young
just read the comments following an
article on almost any article ever
printed it makes you lose complete faith
in humanity that there are human beings
out there walking around that are this
vile this mean and this stupid they
really are I mean it's amazing and of
course they're anonymous which means
they're cowards they have digital
courage only it's got and I do it
sometimes I know better
I'm it's like watching it's a moth drawn
to a flame I should never do this and
you read the comments following an
article I quit doing it Dave it's just
it's the it's the lowest possible common
denominator of and I usually loosely use
the term humanity Oh vile angry racist
pitiful I mean I swear their parents or
cousins unbelievably stupid human beings
always anonymous article comments
there's one going around that everyone's
really fired up about and I've been
people been tweeting me about it and so
James said we need to look at this
article so I like the article it's just
it's just ridiculous when Shawn Cooper
paid off his mortgage in three years he
was so proud he called in a TV crew to
film him burning his mortgage papers but
not everyone celebrated with him in fact
the 30 year olds achievement actually
annoyed a lot of people as Cooper
managed to achieve the unbelievable feat
of Sabai simply being frugal Cooper said
he worked three jobs he was employed
full-time and a pensions consulting firm
while also working at a no-frills
supermarket as a clerk and doing
freelance riding on the weekends and at
night so while people were out having a
good time I was usually inside on my
computer working to cut costs he further
rented out three bedrooms of his home
and lived in the basement right
his bike to work and eating Kraft
dinners of macaroni and cheese the
result is he paid off two hundred fifty
five thousand dollars of a mortgage in
three years and two months and he's
thirty years old it's an achievement
many a lad with a brain would be proud
of but some did not like Cooper's
industriousness and were scathing of his
frugal lifestyle the Facebook page for
the TV station says quote upstanding
citizen works his life away living in
miserable squalor and forgoes human
relationship for years how is this an
inspirational story one bozo said I'm
adding my commentary others didn't want
to applaud another example of white
privilege yet another privileged white
man bragging about how he did it on his
own but did anyone notice how big his
down payment was of the fact that he has
a $75,000 a year full-time job what the
flip is this got to do with him being
white and some of you people
I sure even it's worth get a thick had
some fired up so he took three jobs when
people are struggling to get one so he
can pay his debt off faster while others
by trying to find a job struggled one
woman wrote and we think we know why
you're unemployed some got even more
personal saying they felt sorry for him
if he hopes to woo a mate with whom to
enjoy his financial standing he isn't
going to need applause he's going to
need something to talk about like a
person besides work or frugal ways to
gussy up a kraft dinner one guy says I'm
not particularly happy for him I pity
him he's a model victim of a deranged
cultural ethos that elevates working
money and possessions above all he's
relieved that his house where he barely
lives is paid off great but is he
satisfied with any other aspect of his
life how could he be when has he time to
be we didn't have time to smoke the
amount of dope you do oh my gosh I
applaud this young man for making a
pause not everyone was
rule many with congratulating and most
achievement I applaud this young man for
making a plan and sticking to it three
years in his life working hard and
living frugally and now look at what he
has to offer when he does take a wife a
debt-free home Bravo others wondered
whether Cooper had help in a follow-up
interview Cooper explained that he had
saved a $170,000 deposit on the home on
his own I didn't get any inheritance I
paid for University all by myself so I
certainly wasn't given a free ride by my
parents my mother was a single mother
and I paid her $600 a month in rent when
I was living in her basement the Cooper
acknowledged as a sacrifice to his
social life was probably not worth it I
regret that part he said and I'll tell
you what we need to print up in mass
like get a life cards we could just do
it electronically it would be more
efficient and go ahead and enter them on
the Facebook pages where people say
stupid things like this get a life get
life get a life get a life you know we
really do need to pass out my
grandmother's instructions if you
haven't got anything nice to say don't
say it at all oh man now I'm guilty of
criticizing I'm criticizing right now
I'm criticizing these morons that wrote
these things after this after this young
man had a absolute victory in his life I
might not have gone to the exact same
extremes he went to but he chose to do
that it was his choice and he had he
went to him he took extreme measures and
he got extreme results he's 30 years old
he's a three $400,000 home completely
paid for in cash what do you call that
it except financially successful well
it's not worth it he gave up everything
he has he didn't give up everything he
has he's 30 years old the rest of his
dadgum life as opposed to your but with
a hundred and forty two thousand dollars
in student loan debt and a PhD in German
polka history and then griping to
society ripped you off you think you're
attractive to a mate give me a
Raik loser seriously
Wow so I got to tell you guys um some of
us out here who actually understand what
winning looks like in the real world
need to stand up for guys like this when
the morons come out of the woodwork and
write comments after these things this
the the fact that all the negative
backlash on this happened has become a
viral story that's running rampant and
then bizarre it's become a viral story
because most people agree that the
people writing negative things about
this industrious young guy yeah what do
you do what I've done exactly the same
way no I don't really do crap macaroni
and cheese I might have done beans and
rice rice and beans I mean I might want
a little different flavor there I don't
know goodness gracious
all I got to say to mr. Cooper is your
stud man way to go congratulations from
all of us here at the Dave Ramsey show
and don't listen to the haters they're
not worth listening to this is the Dave
Ramsey show you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others
Oh